(light music)
- The first modern humans
that we know have ever
existed lived in Africa,
and they date to somewhere between 230,000
and 315,000 years ago.
So modern people have been around
in Africa for a very long time.
And then sometime around 80,000 years ago,
it looks like there's
this kind of big movement
out of Africa.
But meantime on the continent of Africa,
a lot was happening too.
And that's when you actually
start to see the first evidence
that there was this really
widespread mingling and moving.
And in terms of what we
find archeologically,
this is when you get a real explosion
in the first art, the first clothing,
the first personal ornaments,
and most of that happens first in Africa.
And all of that continues to kind of grow
and develop and change in
the various parts of Africa,
but we don't know as much about it
as we do other regions
because there just hasn't been
that much research that's been done.
I first went into the Mount Hora area
in Northern Malawi in 2016
because I wanted to see
what the potential would be
to start a new project in that region.
I knew somebody had been
excavating there in 1950
and that not a lot had
happened since then.
So I was interested in the possibility
of actually being able
to retrieve ancient DNA
from this area.
And I did put that in some proposals,
which my colleagues reviewed,
and some of those reviewed said
that it wouldn't be possible
that ancient DNA would not preserve
in these tropical environments
or that the site wouldn't
actually be very old.
And it's been rewarding to be able to see
that both of those things are not true.
The site is actually quite old.
It goes back into the last Ice Age
and some of the ancient DNA
that we've been able to recover from there
is some of the oldest in Africa.
(light music)
So a rock shelter is an area
that's kind of like an overhang
and people will take refuge under there
and they might build fires
or bring home stuff that
they've hunted or whatever.
And so there's some living
activities that happen there
but they also will often
choose those same places
as places of burial.
And what we ended up discovering
was all of the food remains
and the day-to-day activities are recorded
in these rock shelters,
but we also found some human remains.
And some of those human
remains ended up being
some of the oldest that
have been found in the area,
and they are the oldest to
actually preserve ancient DNA
in Sub-Saharan Africa.
So what we did with that,
was we combined it with
a lot other new data
with other teams that had been working
on other parts of that part
of Africa, Eastern Africa,
and we found that when you kind of combine
all of these data together,
it really starts to tell
a a big picture story
about what the ancestral
population structure
looked like long ago.
It's interesting to
think about the timescale
because the actual
individuals that we found,
they range in age from
between about 16,000 years ago
and 14,000 years ago at the
site that we discovered.
But there are also other
individuals in the study,
and they ranged in time all
the way up to 2,000 years ago.
Every one of those
individuals can be thought
of as the product of
all of their ancestors
and all of their ancestors' ancestors.
What we've been able to find by doing this
is that it looks like
people were really doing
a lot of widespread movement.
They're kind of moving
across the landscape,
they're meeting their mating partners,
and then, of course, the
product is a new person.
And that ends up resulting
in all of these people
who live in lots of different places,
but they have this kind of
widespread genetic signal.
And then this interesting thing happens.
You start to notice that genetically,
as well as in terms of
the material culture,
so this stuff that they're leaving behind,
it looks like people are kind
of sticking closer to home.
(light music)
People were making ostrich egg shell beads
in similar ways across
Eastern and Southern Africa.
And then after about 30,000 years ago,
there's divergence in the
styles that they make.
And the hypothesis is
that there was actually sort of barrier
to the movement of people
around 30,000 years ago.
And so that's actually
exactly the same pattern
that we see genetically,
where there's evidence
of widespread movement
and actual contact between people.
And then after about
30 or 20,000 years ago,
right at the peak of the last Ice Age,
those territories get smaller
and people start to
behave much more locally.
So we're actually seeing
it in both the DNA
and and the archeological materials too.
This has required
expertise from researchers
from almost 20 different
countries to do this study,
and the individuals that
we're presenting here,
the ancient individuals come
from recent archeological excavations
such as the one I did
but also from individuals
that had been held in museums.
And so some of my colleagues
were making their contributions
through sampling of those individuals.
And what that means is that
you have to go to museums
and you have to be able to find what it is
that you're looking for,
and you need to be able to know
that it is in good condition.
It shows us how we can connect
the archeological record
to the genetic record,
and that's one of the things we've done
in this paper that we're
really proud of is,
having archeologists co-write it
with geneticists side by
side through the whole thing.
I think one of the biggest lessons here
is that we should always
expect to be surprised.
(light music)